cardi B who showed off her fashion moves
when she arrived at a courtroom in
Queens today best best best best best
donkey cardi turned her court walk into
a catwalk once again looking all
business in black and white suit and tie
but also rocking a fur hat and feather
coat with a 10 to 12-foot train it was
so long and assistant had to trail her
to carry it how you feeling hurting like
I've been in a lot of drama cardi is
facing felony assault charges related to
to strip club brawls she's been to court
several times this year each time in
bold fashions in January she donned a
mink coat fur hat and at least $17,000
Birkin bag April it was a $2,800
Christian Siriano white pantsuit for her
next appearance in May it was this
nearly $5,000 pink suit with a low-cut
blazer and in June she pleaded not
guilty to the charges in a $2,000 blue
suit in a Birkin bag that broke I don't
just an appropiate when I go to court I
just like a young lady where am I
supposed to get my school scramble
[Music]